elle ment des dégâts post m puis aussi
des crayons car sa destinée fatale
cette noix mais nous craignons c'est ce
que tu lis
il date de quand cette chanson pour
lille mais je laisse le temps en 44 elle
a 18 ans sa base est venu pour ça elle
était connue au cours d'une émission de
1 145 d'une émission qui s'appelait sans
rime ni raison le pire la cour et
francis blanche et ensuite je suis passé
dans une émission qui était très coté à
ce moment là qu'ils savaient qu elle
même jean jacques joucla
oui on peut dire que vous aviez été
découvert par la radio à l'époque oui si
je ne dois pas très succinct sur la rtf
saluons mais ses débuts n'étaient pas
tout à fait des débuts disons non non
non je vous avais déjà un peu de métier
heureusement pour moi parce que j'avais
fait un petit matériel pour moi depuis
1942 que je chantais dans l'est dans les
boîtes de nuit
vous avez fait une carrière magnifique
on peut le dire est relativement peu de
temps quelles sont les étapes
importantes
barry a d'abord la chanson déroule
ensuite l'opérette et le cinéma les
jusqu'en 1951
j'avais fait que des choses drôles et
après je suis un petit peu diriger vers
des personnages qui y avait un peu plus
d'humanité et ça a été la seconde étape
aussi bien dans les chansons que dans
mes rôles je faisais
les deux quoi mes patients âgés mais
d'émotions et donc dans la traversée de
paris vous avez même joué un rôle très
dramatique oui mais c'était drôle en
même temps drôle a à mon insu comment se
fait-il que ces personnages dramatiques
que vous vous avez fréquemment au cinéma
les ayez pas porté à la scène encore je
n'ai pas eu l'occasion
on n'a jamais présenté de de deux pièces
vraiment costaud aimeriez oui j'aimerais
bien mais je préfère jouer quand même de
pièce drôle parce que je pense que le
public vient me voir sur scène avec
l'espoir de rire un bon coup comme on
dit et si dans cette pièce il y à
quelques scènes d'émotion
il ira vite n'ai pas envie de changer de
public chérif il faudrait quand même
lille et progressivement mais je ne
pense pas que ce soit encore le moment
je m'en tiens aux pièces qui font rire
c'est une comédie musicale la bonne
planque
oui et c'est denis michel andré il ya
des chansons de détiendra on rit
beaucoup enfin je pense d'ailleurs la
jouer en province les gens je les
entends duré en tout cas et il ya des
scènes d'amour d'émotion oui j'aime
cette ce personnage je vais vous avez
vous un petit bout un tout petit bout et
qu'ils appellent la musique se détériore
un essai du ch en son temps dans
celle-là je chante aussi un touriste
mais je ne chanterai pas triste c'est
difficile
j'ai l'air d'un chanteur de rue avec son
aimée vous ce petit erreur
cette année qui chante à moi
depuis que vous êtes là
alalala l'ain
il est bien ce petit air las
mon gros yeux
si malicieux
en enfer tamer joaillier